here's what would happen if you could  melt metal with your hands  if you wanted to melt metal you'd have  to be a walking furnace Not only would  you be able to melt aluminum Iron and  Steel you'd also be melting just about  everything else you touched but as  quickly as you destroy everything around  you you could just as easily be  destroyed but how well if all of a  sudden it starts raining or someone  happens to throw water on you suddenly a  massive explosion would occur water  reacting with hot molten metal would  create a massive blast of steam if  you're not extremely careful you're  bound to cause severe damage to things  and people you won't want to hurt so  melting metal with our bare hands sounds  like it could be fun but there's no  reason you'd ever want to do it because